I'm gonna use flexbox to create this
layout and then I'm going to give you a
design mock that I want you to provide
the styles for I've got my markup for
the HTML here the first thing I need to
do is setup flexbox on my container
element I need to add display flex and
flex wrap wrap looking at my layout I
can see that some things are out of
order
for example this dark blue box is not in
the same place down here and I want to
make sure they are so in addition to
setting the width of each element I need
to remember to set the order to make
things a bit easier for myself I've
added the styles in the order that the
elements appear the header element is
the first element and it spans the whole
width so I'll set its width to 100 and
ordered a 1 red and orange are next
each looks to be about 50% of the
viewport width so I'll set width equals
50% and order 2 2 & 3 respectively in
this design the footer is next at 100%
width and order equals 4 the next line
is light blue dark blue and green light
blue and green each look like they're
about 20 percent wide dark blue looks
like it's about 60% wide so I'll set
order to 5 6 & 7 on each of those
elements respectively let's compare this
to our sample looks about right to me
let's see how you do